Tổ tập kích sẵn, người bị sò thống bày của Ngá Đánh sấu được tình công hiệp đồng lớn nhất kể từ đầu tháng,
khi gần bốn trong 1w cùng tên lợi chiến thật được chiến khai đồng là,
theo bổ tương lạnh không quân ua quay nè, lực lượng phòng không để đánh trạng hơn 8 chẳng bốn người 1w,
trong lỏ phần lớn bị vô hiệu hãn như biển pháp trì á bị tư.
Tuy nhiên, năm nay bày ua vay và 1 tên lợi Scandheim đã xuyên thùng lợi phòng thủ tấn công vào 12 điểm.
Tổng thống bố lợi miê cho lần ski cho biến, bụt yêu của Ngá là hệ thống năng lượng,
hình định ua khuy nè đang giúp sức khá phục hộ quả,
tình hình tại Kriviri, Kui nhá Ấn, đặc biển nghiêm trọng bởi nhân người làm người bị thương,
trong đó có một hiệu nghiênu quy định.
Rời chứ quay nè cho biến bất đổ tổn thất hiện trước thị thống kê đầy đủ,
chứ khi đó ngá vẫn xửi mlàng.
Bữa kè ngủ khuy nè thiếu hụt tên lợi phòng không, kàng làm ra tăng xế kế,
cho khi chờ việc trở từ phía biến,
tổng thống Mỹ đô đơn trăm tên bố á đặt các bạn mạnh nếu mắt cơv à không đặt thỏe thoại hoa bình trong năm ngày.
Đồng thời cùng gấp dạm tiết par chiếu ở chỗ kí et, qua các nước nát頭.